L'heure est grave les amis !
Toutes les filles des animés
qui nous font rêver !
Non, je ne suis pas puceau !
ont été censurées !
CENSURÉES !!
Devant quoi vais-je me toucher chaque soir ?
Nous devons les libérer !
Nous sommes sur BUSTED !
BUSTED c'est quoi ?
C'est un jeu dans lequel on va libérer toutes ces pauvres filles censurées...
Mais papa n'est pas d'accord
et papa va essayer de nous en empêcher
et nous devons être discrets.
GAME ON !
Jour 1
D'accord, on y passe des jours quand même !
donc je pense qu'on peut peut-être changer d'onglet...
juste...ok
Donc ! On envoie plein de trucs pour les libérer.
Et il y a papa qui peut arriver de plusieurs endroits.
Et je pense qu'il faut...
écoutes...
OUI...?!
Je photoshop ce poisson papou :-)
OK, c'est bon !
Oh, le batard, le bruit d'aspirateur qui met la pression...
Fils de pute !
Eh mec, c'est super long, c'est super long de débloquer l'illustration !
Et pourquoi on n'irait pas sur google, et on tape « fille, animées » ?
Oui...?
J'ai fini le poisson, j'en suis au hibou.
Bah, laisses moi travailler, je suis graphiste enf...
EH, ÇA VA...!
Ah le chien, les nerfs, fils de pute !
Attends, j'ai entendu du bruit, il est au grenier !
MAIS PAPA !
MAIS ÇA VA PAS !!
oh...genre le courant d'air qui ouvre le grenier...
mec c'est trop stressant, c'est abusé...
🎶🎵🎶🎵
nan mais ça va, ça va !!
putain de chien de merde...
j'ai toujours voulu un chat de toute façon...
il y a un bruit,...
il y a un bruit que je ne connais pas...
une sorte de couinement...
c'était en vrai ?
qui vient m'empêcher de libérer les filles nues ?!
EH, C'EST FINIT !
YYYEEESSS !!!
C'est la folie !
On a libérer Samantha, les amis !
Le devoir nous appelle.
Il pourrait y avoir Sakura là dedans !
ou peut-être même...C18
OK, on continue...
Jour 2.
Putain...
C'est génial....
On est le héros de l'animation japonaise, mec.
C'est incroyable.
Ouh, j'ai failli, j'ai failli me foirer !
Ah, le placard mais....
attends...
nan mais mon père va pas être dans le placard...
et comment il atterrit dans le placard ?!
il y a un conduit qui relit le placard à la cuisine ?!
c'est ça ?
putain de psychopathe...
et pourquoi j'envoie des seins pour libérer des...
des....filles
n'importe quoi !
Ouh, c'était limite...!
On libèrera Véronique.
🎵..🎵🎵🎵...🎵....🎵.🎵🎵🎵
on est bon, on est bon, on est bon.
allez...
ah, putain, il enchaîne, il met des feintes, il est fort....!
Papa, tu veux pas juste travailler ?
et gagner ta vie ?
au lieu de faire ça.
Ah, j'avais pas envie de recommencer !
OOUUIIIII !!!
Mon dieu, on en a 2......!
On les libère tel la reine des neiges !
délivrées !
Grâce à moi, vous pourrez télécharger librement ces illustrations, bien évidemment.
Jour 3.
Papa est plus psychopathe que jamais
Il ne dort plus !
ne travaille plus !
il ne p...
oh la la...!
oh la la, l'écran mec
c'est quoi ça ?!
oh la la, la télé mec !
Ouh ah, ça met les infos, ça feinte...!
c'est quoi le téléphone...?
Faut que je réponde...?
Ah non, ça veut dire qu'il est dans le placard, ça...?
j'espère que j'ai été adopté.
mec, ça devient d'une difficulté, c'est abusé. C'est plus dur que Dark Soul
Oui,...j'écrit un roman.....
J.K.Rowling, elle a commencé comme ça...
Elle sauvait des mecs des animés...
et à côté, elle écrivait Harry Potter
C'est alors qu'Harry Potter arriva devant le château....
aller papa !
Tu peux pas test mon SKILL !
Oh, il en reste un !
Oh, putain...!
Oh, on a failli pas avoir la policière !
En plus, les yeux, elles sont pas du tout exceptionnelles mec.
franchement, je suis sûr, si je faisais un twit « dessinez une fille très jolie d'animé »...
vous faites mieux que ça...
Oh la la, mec, il y a 3 élément d'un coup...
faut arrêter là...
Il y a de plus en plus de cases? J'ai l'impression, nan, je rêve ?
Oh. Et il sort de plus en plus vite par contre, ça c'est vrai.
Aaaah !
J'ai eu peur de perdre le sang, mec !
WHAT THE FUCK !
Tu t'es fait chopé...
Il est l'heure de parler...
Papa, c'est pas parce que tu as du mal...
avec les femmes...
qu'il faut m'empêcher de les délivrer.
Elles sont dans une prison de couleur...
Tu comprends ?
continuer...?
Ah, je peux pas continuer ?! What ?!
ça a rien sauvegardé  ?!
Mais nan, c'est un sketch !
Me dis pas « jour 1 » !...
QUOOOIIIIII ???!!!!!!!!...........
NNAAANNNNN !!!!!!!!!!!!!!!.....
SAMANTHAAAA !!!
VÉRONIiiiiiiiiiiQUE !!!
AAAAAHHHHHH !!!!!!!!
NNNOOONNNNN  !!!!!!!
POURQUOOIIIIIII ?!!!!!!!!!
OH !
Oh !...
Oh ?...
Oh ?
Oh ?!.......Oh !
Voilà Voilà, les gens, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur BUSTED. J'spère qu'ça vous a plu.
Putain, j'arr... J'articule même plus
J'espère que cela vous a plus, Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à laisser aimer cette vidéo
Je voulais vous montrer ces jeux trop bizarres.
mais qui me font...
mais ça me fait marrer,
à chaque fois que je cherche des jeux indépendants sur STEAM dans la catégorie « indépendant » ou « petits jeux»...
j'en vois plein défiler.
des fois c'est des simulateurs de rencontres...
y'en a un c'est...
tu joues au SOLITAIRE...
et si tu gagnes, la fille est de moins en moins vêtue.
et c'est que du dessin, donc il n'y a rien de méchant là dedans...
mais je trouve ça super bizarre et un peu malsain...
quitte à passer des heures devant ton PC, autant jouer à un vrai jeu
et puis si tu veux voir des filles d'animés, tu tapes « sexe, animed girl », voilà.
Aujourd'hui, on a fait de la sociologie.
On a étudié ce phénomène qu'est les animed girl
Sous forme de jeu vidéo, c'était palpitant...
y compris pour notre BITE !!
J'aurais dû éviter
Allez à la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien, tchao tout le monde...
PEACE !